[Musique]
nous allons vous conter l'histoire les
aventures des attendus
aventures de renault
renard vallée des engrais
a vécu père est un genre dont nous fera
seul
festin
amora du bâton
[Musique]
au lieu de me maltraiter regarder son
île en grains voici une aventure qui
s'offre à nous ce beau jambon ne vaut-il
pas mieux que ma maigre et chine bien
sûr mais comme on la voir je vous
promets que vous aurez ce jambon et que
vous pourrez vous rassasier un bec
[Musique]
mais je ne goûte guère les rencontres
avec les paysans elle se termine
toujours là coup de bâton laissez-moi
mener la verra bien
[Musique]
[Rires]
en
[Musique]
on
j'espère ysengrin que vous m'avez garder
la part qui me revient sur ce jambon tu
n'es pas sérieux renard tu devrais
estimé bien heureux d'avoir échappé à
mon ressentiment
je te permet de prendre le bâton rien de
plus le bâton je crois bien que ce n'est
pas moi qui le méritent
[Musique]